a lot of times people don't want to talk
about that like oh yeah it's great we're
great friends right but
that could be code for
sure we avoid each other in a room i
mean yeah do you find that element i
mean i guess this is a weird question i
probably shouldn't ask it but
okay i mean so you're achieving a new
level of success which is great
have you seen a new way that people have
treated you like maybe the ones that
weren't nice to you before all of a
sudden now oh ben hey you know we should
do lunch or you know and then the ones
that were like you actually really like
them now they're like more standoffish
with you
um
yeah you know a little bit not not bad
you know i i try to be
in my life just very outgoing and
friendly towards everybody whether they
are less successful than me or more or
the same or somebody i've never met
before or a random audience member i
think everybody's the same as equal
value and
and i think that nobody's more important
than anybody else we're all floating on
this you know vast and noble universal
little bar a little marble in outer
space to think that the the words or the
tasks that i'm performing are more
important than yours is completely wrong
and ridiculous so
um
i think that amount of that that that
amount of perspective helps you
relate to everybody and i think
hopefully i've been able to avoid that
kind of more than most
entertainers for that reason so i've
generally have a pretty good
um
i generally have a pretty good rapport
with people and and i've found that
people just been very happy for the new
level of success i found recently and
generally speaking that is true
um
but
i will say that
you know and i think but you know
weirdly i've in the last couple of weeks
had
very weird instances with two comedian
friends of mine who were both very good
friends and
one i and then both i think just are
acting weird and are seeing things
skewed
um in a weird way so you know one of my
former friends and granted we had a
falling out before this happened but we
had a falling out that was respectful
falling out and then recently got drunk
at the improv and tore my picture off
the wall um and that's something that
you know every comic the back of their
head kind of helps you one picture
the wall at the improv it's like one of
the greatest honors in comedy i think
and
tore it off the wall and clearly that's
some kind of
weird jealousy or some weird you know
anger or not being able i don't know
what it is you know i wasn't there and
i'm not in the person's head but to
it doesn't seem like it's a benign act
you know
so someone told you sorry yeah the club
just told me that it happened and
they're working on getting a new one
printed and getting it back up i guess
but
um so that was pretty weird to
to to
to hear but i think those are anomaly
cases and most those are the times and
the people i think that
are
um
i don't know you know they're probably
going through their own things i tried
and i try not to take it to the kind of
thing too personally i don't think
thankfully i don't have to deal with a
lot of it um
but uh
you can't help but take it a little bit
personally because it's you know but
it's few and far between generally
speaking people seem to be very happy
and hope they are behind my back as well
but seem to be very nice and i've always
been happy for other people's success so
you'd hope to mostly get that in return
we're at the montreal
uh nowhere the vancouver comedy festival
and i was being seen by eddie brill who
was the letterman book of the time and i
did nine minutes of clean material so it
was like two sets back to back and i had
a great great set
and eddie comes backstage and is talking
to me and
he tells me in his first few words like
ben you're great at what you do let me
explain to you though why you're
a year or two away from being on
letterman
he'd already said that and then
continues on to complement the things in
my sense that he liked he walks up and
missed the first two sentences and
missed i did not book the show and it
was just in this like angry like pent-up
thing that he then decided to unload him
he gets in my face between me and eddie
cause he just hears eddie complimenting
me and gets in my face and he goes look
at you with your little cute little
jokes your jokes about candy bars and
your little little huh it's
great for you it must be real nice to be
on the way up on some like that it
was just so
weird and unnecessary you know
um
i've since told him that story and he
apologized for it um doesn't matter it's
just a funny story but um we ended up
doing chelsea lately together a few
times
i love
but people have weird moments you know
i've had weird moments i'm sure as well
you